字幕: Hiroyuki Sugiura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
私は 今から農業の未来について話をします
もともと私 21年間 市場（いちば）で
競り人をしていました
皆さん 「市場」って
どんな所か知っていますか？
簡単に言うと 農産品をたくさん仕入れて
スーパーさんみたいなとこに沢山売る
まぁこんな感じです
ちょっとざっくり言い過ぎですけど
１日の売り上げが「億」
大きな単位なんですね
１パックではなくて
そうだな この会場の100倍ぐらいの
面積が市場の面積で
これが毎日農産品で取引されるぐらいの
スケールの大きなところがこれ「市場」です
そこで私は 荷物をさばいていたんです 毎日
でも 農産品て農家さんの
努力の賜物なんですね
さっき言った「荷物をさばく」
これっていけないことだと思うんですよ
賜物なんですよね
だから「売る」「 農産品」て言わない
過去の私はなんて失礼な販売方法を
してたんだなって すごく今 反省しています
そしてまた当時の私は
全国の産地にも出向いていました
そこで感じたことがあるんです
農家さん 毎年減ってねえかってね
実際減ってるんですよ
これ見てください
めちゃくちゃ減っている
ピークの農家さんが多かった時に比べると
なんと７割減ってるんです
農家さんが減るので
農産品が減るので
ということで
私たち市場の業界も
めちゃくちゃ同じように
売り上げが減ったんです
とんでもない危機感です
農業が衰退する＝市場業界も衰退して
売り上げがなくなるんですよ
仕事がなくなるかもしれないですよね
てこれ 真剣に悩んだんですよ
そこでこの業界の衰退を
どうすれば食い止められるんだろう？
どうすればこれ未来に繋がるんだろうって
結構 真剣に考えた
そこで私はこうやったんです
根本的な解決になるための
手段を考え始めた
ざっくり言うと
今の流れってこんな感じです
農家さんが作った農産品が
卸売業者に流れる
それがスーパーさんに流れて
消費者の皆さんの手に届く
まあ こういう流れなんですね
ということは ここに何か問題があるって
いうふうに私は考えた
もう少し深掘りしてみましょう
農家さんは 今持っている
田んぼや畑やハウスで
いつ何を作ろうって
自ら考えて生産しているんです
で できた農産品を卸売業者さんに
「頑張って高く売ってね」って
お願いする販売が今 主流なんです
これを「委託販売」と言います
受けた側は「委託」—
要は任せられて売るので
市場の競りなどは 相場で売るんですね
要は 農家さんが作った思いや品質で
価格を決定するのがメインではなくてですね
相場で値段が付くんですよ
どういうことかというと
量が多いと安い 少ないと高い
これが相場なんですね
そうすると何が起きるかって
価格が不安定なんです
当然 経営が不安定になる
最悪 「売れない」なんて
可能性すらあるんですよ
まあ ここが要は問題点なんですね
これじゃいけない
そこで無い頭で めちゃくちゃ考えたんですね
どうすればこれ解決できるかなって
ひらめいちゃった
先に売れ先を決めちゃえばいいって
めちゃくちゃシンプルなんです
これなんでできるかというと
私は長く市場にいたんです
今も仲良くしてくれるビッグバイヤーの
流通業者さんがいっぱいいるんですよ
そこで 結構面倒くさい性格でして
しつこく聞いたんです
「何をいい条件で作れば
高く買い取ってくれるんだ」ってね
しつこく真剣に聞いたんで
まあ結構みんな答えてくれたんですよ
いやいやですけど
要は そういう答えがあったんです
作る農産品、品質、価格 —
ここで決まりました
そこで私は 農家さんに求められた農産品を
作ってもらうようにお願いするようにしました
そして私がお願いした農産品なので
農家さんの農産品を私が全量買い取ります
そして私もバイヤーさんからお願いされた
農産品が目の前にあるので
それを全量販売するということを
今 実際やっています
これによって農家さんは
「本当にこれってしっかり
売り切ってくれるかな」とか
「いくらで売れるんだろう」とか
「売れないなんてことないよな」みたいな
その不安から解消されるようなことが
今 私のこのことで実現するようになったんです
要は出口を先に決めたんです
これが非常に重要
だけどシンプル でも難しい
けど 私なりに今できている
けど これだけでは なかなか
うまくいかなかったんですよ
求められる品質、量、安定生産という
その栽培技術って すごいハードルが
高いことに気づきました
農家さんがなかなか増えないとか
やめてしまう理由が
経営が不安定っていうものと
もう一つ 栽培技術がすごい難しいって
いうことが挙げられます
聞いたことありませんか
「匠の技術」って
なんとなくって言ったら 怒られますけど
知識と経験と勘から
得られるものが「匠の技術」
これって すごい長い年月がかかるんですね
ひょっとしたらですね
その栽培している品目とか 場所が変わると
全く使い物にならないっていう
技術でもあるんですよ
でもそれだと 私は求められている
品質と農産品が決まっているので
うまく流通させないと 怒られてしまうんです
そこで 栽培技術の確立が急務になったんです
そして３年間試行錯誤の結果
こんな技術を確立しました
見てください
これロックウールと言いまして 工業製品
よく 住宅などの壁の
断熱材で使われる材質です
サイズが６センチ×６センチ
めちゃくちゃ小さいんですよ
要は根っこを小さくしたんです
トマトってよく ストレスをかけると
おいしくなるって言われる農産品です
これ実際そう
匠の農家さんは —
ほとんどの方が土で作りますね —
匠の技術で
大きな根っこをコントロールして
より良い農産品やトマトを作る技術がある
けどさっき説明しました この匠の技術
うまく手に入らないんです
そこで逆のことをやったんです
根っこを小さくすることによって
コントロールする栽培技術
ということを思いついて
この確立を私はしたんです
こっから先 本当はあんまり言いたくない
じゃあその肝は何か —
水やりだったんです
水やりをコントロールする栽培技術です
これをコンピューター制御
することに成功したんです
ただ コンピューターで制御することが
正解じゃないんですよ
何が正解？
農学の理論に基づいてコンピューター制御する
ことが非常に重要だということです
なぜかって「匠の技術」
経験と勘が重要ですね
それを農学の理論ならば
論破出来るだろうと私は考えたんです
しかも 難しい技術の継承という
ハードルを上げている農業の現場
この技術を使えばハードルが
下げられるだろうというふうにも考えたから
これを私は取り入れた
実際
トマトは夏場 この暑い時期って
うまく作れないんですよ
ただ 私が作ったこの技術で
今 結構作ることに成功しています
それはなぜかというと
この技術を使うことの この栽培の
マニュアル化に成功したからです
実際 私のグループ会社の
農業未経験の若者たちが
このマニュアルによって
一年中高品質で
めちゃくちゃ美味しいトマトを
作ることに成功しています
これリアルです
そしてですね ただそれだけじゃ
あんまりインパクトがなくて
高額なお金をかけたハウスではなくて
私がやっているのは 農業の居抜きビジネス
みたいなこと言われるんですけども
安い中古のビニールハウスを
活用してこれを実現したんです
今結構 興奮して喋ってるんですけどね
多分皆さんわかんない
でもこれ 農家さんとか農業界から言わせると
とんでもない技術革新なんですね
ちょっとすいません
自己満足で喋ってます
（笑）
で 今後このマニュアルをですね
農業を始めたいという農業未経験の方や
今 栽培うまく出来ないって
悩んでる方に提供していく
これでやっと私が考えた流通の
この新しい品質基準から求められる仕組みが
農産品が確保できるので
「やったね できたな」と思ったんですよ
甘くないですね 世の中ねぇ
問題が起きました
クレームなんです
「宮地から言った農産品 百貨店で高い[けど]
おいしいとお前言ったじゃないか」って
「買ったら美味しくなかった」って
結構クレームがあったんですよ
これは何かって言うと
買おうとしている消費者の皆さんが
この求められるトマトとか農産品
今買おうとしている物の
「品質の基準」がよくわかっていないと
いうことに私は気づきました
今 喋ってる最中に「品質」「 基準」
「そんなあるやんけ」って思う人は 多分いる
これですよ これこれ「糖度」
今 一般的な基準って「糖度」なんですね
数値が高ければ高いほど 甘いって言われる
結構みんなそう思ってるでしょ？
でも「 糖度＝甘さ」でも 実はないんです
これ見て下さい
これ衝撃的ですよ
これ糖度計と呼ばれる機械で
トマトとレモンを同じ機械で
同じ時間に測った数値
9.7度を表している
すごい高品質なフルーツトマトが
８度以上と言われるので
この9.7のトマトは めちゃくちゃ甘い
実際食べました
めちゃくちゃ美味しかったです
これ酸っぱさの代表格でもあるレモン
普通のスーパーさんで買ったレモンなんで
何ら特別なレモンではない
みんな「甘いレモンや」って思ってるでしょ？
当然 酸っぱいんですよ
酸っぱい
糖度計なんですよ
同じ時間に同じ機械で
これおかしいと思いませんか
じゃあ この9.7は何かっていうと
甘さや酸っぱさなどが合算した数値が
ただ表されているだけなんです
イマイチわかんないですかねぇ？
はい わかんない人
よくわかんないね
はい はい
これはですね 要は明確に
甘いとか酸っぱいとかの品質が
この糖度計では表されていないと
いうことなんですよ
ただ 農家さんは この糖度計の数値を基に
より良いものを作ろうと日々努力されている
私たち卸売業者や消費者の皆さんはこの数値を
基に売り買いしているのが今の現実なんです
何度も言いますけども
私が新しく作ろうとしてる流通の仕組みは
先に品質基準を決めて
販売価格を決めると言っています
そうすると今の糖度基準と言われる
一般のこの基準だと
甘いか酸っぱいがよくわからないのが
今の基準なんですね
そうするとまた私
クレームで怒られちゃうんですね
これじゃ困るんですよ
そこでまた考えたんです
ひらめいちゃうんですね 結構ね
生産者、卸売業者、消費者
共通の新しい品質基準を作ってしまえば
「これカバーできるよな」って思ったんですよ
そこで今開発しているのはこれ
「FTIRセンサー」
これ格好いいでしょ
これちょっとイメージです イメージ
（笑）
これ赤外線という光が
ピッて当たるんですね
まあ出るんですよ
それで 糖度じゃなくて
甘いとか酸っぱいとか
リコピンみたいな有機物が
測れるセンサーなんです
しかもこれは持ち運びができるように
小型化したセンサーになっていて
2021年までに完成させる
これ結構衝撃的な絵でして
これ実は2021年にできると
ワールドプレミア
世界初のセンサーなんですね
おおって言うとこですよ （笑）
まあいいや はい
で これをですね 小型化して
現場で持ち運びができるようになるので
農家さんの現場で言うと
ピッと当てると「あ これはもう
収穫できるよね 美味しいよね」とか
なんなら１か月くらい前に
青い状態のトマトにピッて光を当てると
「１か月後に このぐらいのね
言われたトマトに作らないといけないから
こういう栽培をして行こう」みたいな
現場ではそのように使える
要は 栽培技術の向上にすごい関与できる
ようなセンサーになるんですよ
で 私たち業者や消費者の皆さんは
何がメリットがあるかってこれです
さっきの糖度計
よくわかんない9.7度でしたね
甘いか酸っぱいかって
いや本当にでも酸っぱかったですからね
でもこのセンサーを使うと
明確に 甘さや酸っぱさを区別して
表示することができるセンサーなんです
じゃあ これがなんで必要かって
３回目です
私が 新たに作ろうとしている流通の仕組みは
品質基準を決めて販売価格を決める
この仕組みなんです
先ほどの糖度計だと
よくわからない曖昧な品質基準でしょ？
だから困るということで
このセンサー開発をしているんです
そうすると皆さんは
狙った好みのトマトとかレモンとか
桃とかが買えるような世の中が
今 もう少しで目の前に来ている
まあこれが現実です
結構 楽しみにしていてください
これから私は この農業界の
ハードルが高いというこの技術確立
これを私たちの この技術を使うことで
誰でもできる農業の実現をまずさせていく
これを入口です
そして出口
売るじゃダメなんです
売り切らないとダメ
じゃあどう売り切るかって
言った
先に品質と販売価格を決定してしまうので
もう売り切れるんですね
これで入口と出口が決まった
けど曖昧な品質基準じゃダメです
言ったですね
共通の品質基準 これを強固につなげる事で
一つのサービスに成り立つ
これによって この業界の未来が
私は開けるっていうふうに信じています
いつか
農業未経験の若者たちが 農業を仕事にする
そんな当たり前の世界観を
私は作っていきたい
それまでチャレンジを続けます